I think we all know I am here and I
think I just realized up the bullcrap
what quiet quiet something we need to
celebrate quit I'm talking Jesus uh well
listen to me night is special
yes I'm here because so yeah I just feel
like ah Kate remember it was almost glad
that you introduced us
I'm talking here jeez God I'm here do
you remember yes we're gonna have a
menage oh wow without you we wouldn't
even have this celebration so so do you
want donut maybe you can give me yours I
went running not decorating dough is my
dog wasn't no look I'm giving up man
killing him you're like do you like it
there me woman David you are the man I
avow not gives me do you have it or not
give me a kiss you like five times were
you hunting me smile you can't give up
Kate when I was evening is over you guys
been a lot you know what you can expect
a racist you never know why me oh man
sniffing her thunder
so what's your poison how about a
martini how about a penis all right
let's try this trip hey are you a
homosexual
Hey oh that that's just a little joke
perhaps soon oh well well well what no
my nipples will be that shallow what
does this picture make you think oh my
god I think uh oh sorry one word okay it
will have to be pubic hair it's a two
word I got damn it oh man all right
there's romance ha party next weekend
bro you think you can make it bro
brah it's gonna be great bro I don't
have time for parties so what have you
two been talking about it yeah uh-huh
yeah busy um
hahaha hey his face his face no no no I
was just kidding I was just kidding come
on come on come on take a joke
wait what is it taking me wait right
over there the wall are you fine
you uh yeah um you know what I'm talking
about okay George
melih hey god it's been so long since
we've seen you
what what you don't like melon I love
melon I don't give me that look
Oh No oh no he didn't he I I just wanted
to give him a melon I don't understand
can I put you down huh then I gotta open
this door I don't want you maniac u6 I'm
not a section maniac you guys are
freakin crazy
take a sauna with you you're thinking of
leaving yes
you guys suck okay let's go Savona I
don't need them and I don't need it and
I'm gonna leave I just love you sucks
why is he going yeah I go back to get
throw in to throw me out what [ __ ] how's
it going rest my name is Pete back hope
you bros enjoyed this facade montage if
you did why not give it a like and share
it it really helps out a lot or even
better yet subscribe and become a bro
today also be sure to leave a comment
telling me which one of these moments
where your favorite and that's pretty
much it here comes the bro
founded by a dog
you